As promised, the first thing we'll touch upon is coming to Unreal Engine from other engines.
So if you are familiar with maybe Unity or Godot or some other kind of licensed engine
that you might have been using, some of the terminology may be similar, may be different,
and today's class is hopefully just going to help onboard you a little bit better
into Unreal Engine so it's not as overwhelming for you.
So some of the terminology will be different, maybe GameObjects, Actors, and Scene
components in the different engines might be different, but if you look at the middle row
here, Components, Components, and Nodes, these are all kind of similarities that might be shared
across the engines. So if you're thinking in terms of something was named something in one
engine and it might be slightly different in the other engine, we can look at these
like prefabs in Unity, might be blueprint classes inside of Unreal.
So hopefully the terminology doesn't get too confusing.
If you are imprinted with terminology and names from other engines, we've listed two
really good resources here that will really help you get your head around using Unreal
Engine and the terminology associated with it. So if you go to the Epic Developer Community forums,
we've got something called Unreal for Unity Developers, which is a really good getting started
in UE5 course if you're familiar with Unity. And then there's also a really great resource
on YouTube, which Alex Forsythe has developed, which talks about Actors and Components and
Inheritance and Composition across the various engines. So if you are familiar with other
software, I definitely recommend touching these two resources as well as today's course to help
give you a more rounded overview. Now, starting with the concept of Actors inside of Unreal
Engine, you'll hear the word actor a lot in this image. You can see a lot of different things
happening. It may feel overwhelming, but in the very top right of the image that you'll see here,
it says parent class actor. And you'll notice that everything in Unreal Engine
is an actor to an extent, which is a scriptable entity
of themselves. So they can use coded logic, they may have inheritance,
another class, but at the very highest level will have this actor class. And if you see the
green box on the left hand side of the image here, you'll see all a list of components,
which can be actors within themselves. So you'll see a scene route, which then has a cube
mesh, a little static mesh component attached to there, and then a point light. And you'll just
see a list of these components here. So if I've selected the point light, which I have in this
blueprint, you'll see, for example, on the right hand side where that red arrow is, it has some
location values. So it's got a vector there associated with the location in X, Y, and Z.
And you'll see that each actor and each component that I have selected has multiple
editable properties. So an actor with scene components will have,
you know, one component as their route, which then acts as the transform of the actor itself.
So hopefully that's not too overwhelming of an image to share. It's kind of useful to get
familiar with this terminology and how Unreal Engine sets up its behavior by default,
but we'll get plenty into more detail of actors to help demystify some of these
concepts that you might be experiencing.